oh gosh we got a lot of fact checking to
do hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome
to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we'll be taking an updated look at
what san flute eats in a day but first
let me tell you about my sponsor
buildbar it is built bar o'clock over
here aka snack time and these bars are
really unlike any other protein bar i've
tried because they actually taste like a
candy bar not chalky not powdery not
mealy oh no and there's so many fun
flavors and this is one of my faves
cookie dough chunk
i'm running low on these ones because i
am going through them oh so good 15
grams of protein
[Music]
oh
so many big chunks in there so much
delicious chocolate and you guys know
what i say about the zero guilt thing
unless you stole them from a baby all
foods are zero guilt these are one of my
go-to bedtime snacks with like a piece
of fruit or i love to use them on top of
oatmeal or yogurt to turn them into
hunger crushing combo snacks so if you
want to give these a try check out the
link in my description and use my promo
code abbeysharp15 to get 15 off of your
order and you can pause the screen or
look at the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating as
always feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey and
if you are new here hello don't forget
to subscribe to this channel and ring
that little bell so you never miss out
on a video and also follow me over on
tick tock and instagram abby's kitchen
all right so this is not our first rodeo
with sun as we have reviewed her not
once but twice on the channel so if you
missed those videos you can check them
out right here but this time she's back
to discuss another hot and trendy topic
in the world of wellness hormones so
let's jump right in and see what she
eats for hormone balance what i always
have in the morning is to smartchat and
then i make a little foam layer with oat
milk and a tiny bit of maple syrup and i
just scoop the foam on it when i start
my day straight with coffee i'm just
like i don't know i just feel so jittery
and like kind of on edge okay so i spoke
about this when i discussed fellow angel
romy's diet but this is actually an
evidence-based observation so the amino
acid l-theanine in matcha provides the
alertness that we want from the caffeine
but because it helps the body absorb the
caffeine at a slower rate we tend to
avoid that sudden crash
so a lot of folks who are slow
metabolizers of caffeine find themselves
less jittery and anxious with this
matcha swap
i am going to journal right now it's my
morning step
and then i'm probably gonna do
like a 30 minute pilates workout talk
about a that girl moment
i just have to point out how unnatural
it feels to like set up a camera for
something that's supposed to be as zen
and introspective as journaling so
yeah if you're ever wondering how real
life these videos are not much friends
not much first thing i have in the
morning is my athletic green supposed to
have this on an empty stomach
basically a daily nutrition supplement
full of like vitamins minerals it's
really good for gut health energy and
overall immune system this tastes really
good and it also doesn't have
artificial sweeteners or any other
sweeteners like monk fruit and things
like that okay so i get so many
questions on my weekly amas about
athletic greens specifically so i think
it's time to talk first of all what i
like so athletic greens are third party
tested nsf certified so it definitely
meets very high standards for purity and
verification the vitamins here are in
their high quality bioavailable forms
like methylated b12 and methylfolate and
you're getting some functional
ingredients digestive enzymes and
probiotics which for the most part
doesn't hurt i think one of my concerns
however is the general assumption that
more is more
what we often end up with in these
situations is what i call a lot of
window dressing so basically we see a
huge list of all these functional
ingredients as part of like a
proprietary blend but we have zero clue
how much is actually in the product and
if that amount would yield a clinical
efficacious dose so since a serving is
just 12 grams and there are 75
ingredients listed many of which have an
efficacious dose of like one to ten
grams each i think it's safe to assume
you're often not gonna get amounts that
actually work not to mention that there
are a number of nutrients here with
significantly more than one's daily
needs the result of which is really just
very expensive the other concern i have
are based around the claims that san
makes here which are very common claims
that i've seen used to promote these
kinds of supplements online and i would
really need like a full video to unpack
this but we could do it very quickly so
let's start with the claim about energy
so some of the b vitamins here may help
to support energy metabolism but they're
unlikely to boost energy levels if
you're not legitimately deficient a
breakfast with more substance than a
scoop's 50 calories is much more likely
to give you the energy that you crave
next let's talk about immunity so i see
this product as basically like a
powdered multivitamin so supplements may
support immunity through their
antioxidant content but vitamins do not
boost our immune system and if they did
like i would say it's missing one of the
most important immune supporting
nutrients which is vitamin d and finally
is the claim about being good for gut
health so this blend does contain some
digestive enzymes which may be
beneficial for some people who are
deficient but not necessary for everyone
plus some probiotics to help populate
the gut now i've seen a lot of
influencers claim that ag-1 is great for
reducing bloating and i would say that
if you're consuming this in lieu of like
fiber-rich fruits and vegetables and
you're sensitive to high fiber loads
then yeah it might be a gentler option
but interestingly a lot of folks with
bloating ibs or fodmap sensitivity
actually have sibo and there are a lot
of ingredients here that would not be
bloat friendly for some of these
sensitive folks so inulin fiber apple
powder slippery elm shiitake mushroom
powder and even the probiotics can all
trigger bloating in a lot of folks plus
the two grams of fiber in the powder is
never going to replace the natural fiber
inherent in whole fruits and veg so as
with all supplements or multivitamins
please do not think that this is a
complete replacement for whole food so
is it worse than 99 a month i mean maybe
depends on the person their budget and
their nutritional gaps in their diet i
really see greens powder like a premium
multivitamin which may be really helpful
for some folks who can afford it but i
would say that the vast majority of
people that i see drinking this stuff
online are really the last people to
actually need it case in point let's
take a look at the rest of sun's very
produce packed day
[Music]
uh delicious so we are getting some
protein fiber and healthy fats from both
the peanut butter and chia seeds which
are really built in hunger crushing
combos and while that gives us around 12
grams of protein i am mindful that this
is a post-workout meal so somewhere in
the neighborhood of like 20 to 30 grams
of protein for muscle protein synthesis
would be ideal so i would recommend a
higher protein plant milk like soy milk
or pea protein milk instead of the oat
milk which only has one gram of protein
per half cup or she could mix some
protein powder into her oat milk to
really just help bump it up
[Music]
i didn't really drink a lot of coffee at
all but i was feeling one today so i
made one you know the drill
no comment on the coffee i am never
gonna judge a woman for needing a midday
boost okay
we are going to make a veggie sandwich
for lunch i personally love a good
sourdough rather than a more like
processed type of bread if that makes
sense um i think as long you buy things
from like high quality and like
something fresh it's also a way how i
incorporate
more carbohydrates into my diet and
which have helped me with my hormones as
well when i eat a lot of oats for
example i feel very heavy well even if i
eat a lot of like the high quality bread
i don't feel happy okay it is 2022.
let's set the record straight here
unless you have diagnosed celiac disease
or gluten allergy or intolerance there
is no need to avoid gluten it will not
make you healthier and you may end up
sacrificing a lot of flavor nutrition
and variety now i am also team sourdough
team it feels good and you know you
should we know that the slow
fermentation process of sourdough helps
to kind of pre-digest the gluten making
it easier to tolerate in folks with
gluten or fodmap sensitivity the
fermentation process also produces
prebiotic and probiotic properties which
might explain why eating sourdough bread
makes her feel good or kind of less
heavy as she puts it compared to some
other carbs sourdough however is not
gluten-free so it is not appropriate for
folks with celiac or diagnosed gluten
intolerance as for whether or not carbs
help with hormonal regulation there is
limited research suggesting that
following a low-carb diet for a long
period of time may negatively impact
hormones and cause amenorrhea so one
small study found that 45 of women who
followed a keto diet for six months
experienced disturbed menstrual cycles
while 30
experienced amenorrhea and this is
potentially because under consuming
carbs or calories suppresses the hormone
leptin which is really essential for
maintaining normal menstrual function
especially in folks who are already very
lean so sourdough is amazing but it's
probably not enough it really comes down
to consistently eating enough calories
and carbs and protein and fat
[Music]
this looks amazing so if you love hummus
mashed chickpeas is like a really simple
diy version with slightly more protein
than the spread that said well i think
this looks like an amazing hearty
sandwich with lots of healthy fats and
fiber plus around 600 calories we're
still only getting around 13 to 15 grams
of protein here so a lot of folks might
find themselves more satisfied if maybe
we added greek yogurt into the mashed
chickpeas or adding like a slice of
marinated tempeh or tofu my hormonal
imbalance notice like my periods are
getting a little more
regular and things like that every body
is um is different and i don't really
want to give like
i would say
medical advice we increase my fat and
protein intake because growing muscle is
really important it's really good for
like the fuel hormone estrogen so i was
doing a little bit more weight training
and then i was incorporating tons of
healthy fats by adding coconut oil with
like chickpeas and
salmon so we did a blood test on each
carbs and see how much it spiked in my
sugar level turned out sourdough bread
and rice were actually the most
beneficial for me also adding like flax
seeds and like chia seeds and like
superfoods so in another one of sans
videos she shares that she struggled to
get her period back after going off of
birth control and her medical team
speculated that this may have to do with
like a low body fat percentage and of
course also stress and given the nature
of her career in the modeling industry
she was really primed for non-stop
travel and likely a lot of pressure to
maintain like a size zero frame so in an
effort to get her period back she added
more healthy fats and carbs into her
diet while also being more open to
gaining some weight so we already
discussed the importance of carbs but
the other two macros are also very
important for fertility and hormonal
health for fat research suggests that we
want to aim for at least 0.8 to 1 gram
of fat per kilogram of body weight for
optimal hormonal health and for protein
we know that a low protein diet has been
linked to low growth hormone low
estrogen and ovulation autoimmunity and
compromised thyroid function most
importantly though is calories a woman's
body is smart as
when we under eat we see a down
regulation of sex hormones thyroid
hormone output and also often libido
hypothalamic amenorrhea expert dr nicola
mccarty of no period now what who i
actually spoke to for my video here
suggests a minimum of 2500 calories a
day and no heavy exercise if you've lost
your cycle and are trying to get your
reproductive hormones back in check and
as we saw on stephanie buttermore's
all-in journey that protocol might be
warranted even if the woman is still
technically ovulating but their hormones
still aren't in an optimal place also
hormonal health is not just about what
or how much we eat san has talked about
tending to her mental health to help
restore her cycle which really does make
sense because you know our menstrual
cycles are heavily influenced by stress
so basically our stress hormone cortisol
down regulates all of our reproductive
hormones like gonadotropin releasing
hormone luteinizing hormone and follicle
stimulating hormone as for the practice
of adding flax and chia seeds to our
diet this is a common suggestion with
the practice of seed cycling which i
actually wrote a whole blog post on
right here so i will link to that below
the idea is that flaxseed contains
phytoestrogens that in a sense mimic the
chemical structure of estrogen so it's
believed to help balance endogenous
estrogen and while there is some
research to suggest that phytoestrogens
may be associated with cycle regularity
in general the research on seed cycling
is quite limited but at the end of the
day these are very nutritious calorie
dense little meal or snack editions so i
would say that they could only help not
intermitting fasting was also a big one
i used to kind of like skip over
breakfast but it is really important for
female hormones to actually
have breakfast so she is right
i actually discussed this in a lot more
detail in my video on intermittent
fasting and hormones but when i spoke to
my colleague eric williamson he
suggested that the safe fasting length
for a woman really depends on how much
she eats when she eats how many feedings
she has when she exercises and how much
and whether her daily total is in a
energy balance or significant deficit
but generally speaking
16 hours which is a very common
intermittent fasting regimen is far too
long for most women to safely go without
food it is my cortisol levels because
when you feel stressed or when your body
is in pain or when you're over trained
your cortisol levels will go up in your
body and this has a huge huge huge
negative effect on female hormones
so what did i do
i learned how to say no to things to
give my body more rest and really like
cut out those like stress triggers out
of my body i worked on my shoulder pain
so my body was less in pain so
less cortisol so she is right and it's
not just cortisol that can get out of
whack from over training thyroid
hormones ostrom estrogen progesterone
b12 iron can all be affected which can
impact ovulation and reproductive
hormones but it's not enough to just
think about being gentle in the gym for
healthy cortisol levels it's also best
to focus on gentle nutrition as well so
one interesting study on cortisol and
dieting divided women into two fully
cross-controlled experiments where some
monitored or tracked their calories and
some did not i did not and some
restricted their calories and some did
not and they found that restriction
increased cortisol levels and even the
women who monitored or tracked their
calories that didn't restrict their
calories had significant increases in
perceived stress so conclusion dieting
is not great for your body you know when
i went to my doctor the first time they
just looked at me and they were like
yeah you're too skinny you just need to
gain weight i mean this advice isn't
great and definitely could use a touch
of bedside manner but it also isn't
technically wrong as we know that being
underweight can impact the production of
reproductive hormones however for some
folks it's really not as easy as just
kind of like simply telling them to eat
more food without it feeling
uncomfortable so son herself expressed
in her video that it was difficult for
her to gain weight even when she tried
to eat like a higher volume of food
because it simply just did not align
with her hunger cues now i discuss
sustainable weight gain strategies in my
video right here but some general
strategies are to focus on adding lots
of fats like oils nuts nut butters and
seeds which it seems like she does to go
easy on the volume rich veggies to add
more calories to drinks like smoothies
and to also not shy away from lower
fiber foods like white rice or bread
which she is also evidently doing i also
have to note that the title of this
video how to stay lean and find hormonal
balance is in a lot of cases
incompatible or at least feels really
contradictory like what is the goal here
hormone balance or maintaining a model
figure like the message just seems a bit
muddy to me
[Music]
[Music]
two
lettuce wraps one with salmon one
chicken normally i don't really mix it
up but i had leftovers this spread looks
delicious and i like that we're not
sacrificing the carbs here by adding in
the rice on the side we're also getting
two types of protein and we're seeing
more healthy fats here with the salmon
pepitas and cashew dressing in the salad
i would say that this is a great example
of how to sneak in extra calories
through sauces dressings nuts and oils
without feeling like you're eating an
enormous overwhelming meal
kind of dessert i kind of addicted to
these dark chocolate from the kitchen i
feel like dark chocolate and tea are
just made for each other so
i think this is a really great late
night snack okay so to sum this up super
quick sun is averaging a healthy amount
of calories for a woman her size but is
still significantly less than you know
dr rinaldi's suggestion for period
restoration now i do believe she's
already restored her period but there is
still some hormonal optimization to do
so upping the calories a bit more
may be warranted it's important to note
that some women's normal weight might
not be their best fertile weight i would
also say that while i love to see all
those healthy fats she's still averaging
on the lower end of the suggested
protein and carb macro range so i would
just make sure that we're not
sacrificing one macro to accommodate
another and if that helps us sneak in a
few extra 100 calories i think it can
only help to support her hormonal health
goals so on that note folks that's all
that i have for you guys today thank you
again to buildbar for sponsoring if you
like this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
what you'd like to see me real for you
next subscribe to the channel and i will
see you next time on abby's kitchen
[Music]
bye you